[Musica]
qualcuno ha sentito parlare di software
open source o open design non stata pure
la mano open design è uno dei suoi
esempi software open source è solo
un'idea potentissima
immaginate di andare a cena al
ristorante o da un nemico e immaginate
che ho della pietanza che viene servita
viene offerta vi sia la fa anche la
ricetta per farla è nato lista degli
ingredienti tempi procedure e metodi per
il risultato finale
questa cosa sembra banale ma in realtà
permette di fare qualcosa di molto
interessante poter guardare al turista
di ingredienti e magari polare
verificare se c'è qualcosa che siete
allergici
potete farne delle varianti faccio la
versione vegetariana delle lasagne della
nonna
potete distribuire questa ricetta agli
amici a cui maria fede la pietanza i
quali a loro volta magari la lavoreranno
faranno delle altre varianti da cosa
nasce cosa
qualcuno sento parlare di linux
stiamo sempre la mano ad inox è
probabilmente il risultato più di
successo del software open source
forse quello più popolare forse quello
più nota difficile misurare l'impatto
però è un interessante questo linux
compie 25 anni è nato nel 91 una
cameretta di un ragazzo all'epoca
ragazzo giovane uomo fino al mese come
un progetto per passare tempo dalla noia
direi
collegandoci al fantastico precedente e
premio di cinque anni ne ha fatta di
strada ne ha fatta di strada perché dopo
25 anni
come dicevo è forse la cosa come scala
collaborativa sul livello globale più
importante che abbiamo forse assieme a
wikipedia parliamo di lo cose diverse
però per darvi un'idea magari avete più
femminilità come che vide che con linux
solo i numeri su cui non vogliono fissa
se mai vi danno un'idea di del tasso di
progressione di collaborazione che
questo pezzo di software cosa software
sap ed è quella cosa che fa funzionare
il cellulare che avete in tasca il
computer una richiesta il termostato di
casa funzione di questi pezzi di ferro
che chiamiamo
iuter cellulare questa è alla base di
molte di questi oggetti che usiamo
quotidianamente
ma non è solo un hobby lobby del
finlandese
abbiamo delle organizzazioni tra i primi
dieci sviluppatori c'è tra i primi dieci
che dicono sì contiamo a farla questa
cosa tutti assieme e anzi siamo tra i
primi a crederci che non sono
sicuramente delle una profit nomi come
questi che abbiamo sulle slide pensate
anche cosa succederebbe se si fermasse
non ho problemi a tenere le
infrastrutture soprattutto di
telecomunicazioni è anche sempre più
quelle civili cosiddette la rete
elettrica e compagnia bella tutto
partito dall'ira di questo ragazzo che
ha detto ma condivido questa ricetta per
fare questo pezzo di software ora perché
hanno prato di linux è un ottimo esempio
dell'open design stanziato nel software
open design non è solo software open
source e anche open hardware e anche
copen d'età questo però è sempre un
concetto che ruota attorno è fatto di
collaborare ma solo un attimo indietro
nel tempo a dieci anni fa ero uno
studente in cerca di un argomento per
fare la tesi di laurea qui a padova è un
professore recato la mia attenzione con
i robot che dovevano entrare in scena di
lì a poco degli avanzamenti scientifici
molto interessanti questi robot potevano
finalmente almeno su carta percepire il
mondo in cui si muovevano capire come
generale traiettorie per operare in
questo mondo
entusiasta iniziarono raci qui e poi un
po in giro per il mondo però il
progresso e raramente lento risultato di
una tesi di sei mesi non ha desiderato i
quattro anni era qualcosa che forse
andava bene per scriverci un articolo a
mandarlo però qualcuno di voi sa fondere
da alcuni veicoli guida o trono ma ne
sentiamo parlare tessler bene questi
sono degli ottimi esempi su come la
robotica senta nel nostro mondo sono
degli oggetti che percepiscono da niente
attorno a sé e decidono come muoversi
disegni fa appunto quando stavo cercando
largamente di te e di me prime
competizioni della darpa ed esalto nel
nevada sono questi veicoli che grossi
teen di molte persone provavano a
ingegnerizzare e che forse riuscivano
forse in molte ore a concludere un giro
su perseguito chiuso senza ostacoli
ora dopo dieci anni mi stavo per la
soddisfazione finalmente questa anni fa
anch'io un giro su questi veicoli vedo
autonoma fantastici molto più precisi di
un pilota romano devo dire questi
signori che mi spiegavano come
funzionava la cosa
nessuna mano sul volante come vedete mi
hanno spiegato come fanno questo è non
mi ha sorpreso la cosa queste dell open
source è alla base di molte innovazioni
tra cui quella che sta vivendo nel campo
della robotica ed in più a di veicoli
vedono ma un'altra soddisfazione che mi
sono dato quest'anno è stata lunedì
quando il signore che forse ora se non
di giudicare il pad dell'incarnazione
più moderna di linux
ci ha confermato non ho ancora trovato
uno di questi veicoli che non sia basato
su questo pezzo open source pensate alla
cameretta del fino al mese
e pensate anche che questo pezzo di
software fa andare tanto nel cellulare
fa andare tanto il sistema che usate in
qualche server per scrivervi con
whatsapp o agli amici fa andare a questi
veicoli ora il fatto che non sia una
cosa banale mi ha indicato datati come
questi parliamo di società start up che
ha un po un termine in voga per dire pmi
di belle speranze che in tre anni con
uno staff di al massimo 40 persone come
cruz a auto unisce in questo caso
arrivano sviluppano tecnologia basandosi
su questi strumenti che è valutata un
miliardo di dollari è un acceleratore
fondamentale oppure per guardarla
dall'altro punto di vista quanto può
fare una persona oggi è dotata di questi
strumenti può fare una persona sia
giorgio il suo prototipo in casa
attaccandolo la sua honda un computer a
telecamera e andare in giro festa di san
francisco non fatelo a casa i giorni sta
che se l'auto in giro ha avuto qualche
momento interessante però una persona
quando fino a pochi anni facciano
centinaia di tecnici provano risultato
molto inferiore
ora torni a un attimo indietro open
source si sta a stanziare una robotica
da molto vive negli atti dispositivi che
sappiamo c'è un'altra honda che sta per
arrivare di cui parlano molto gli
addetti ai lavori ma di cui
probabilmente sentirete parlare sennò ed
è già sentito parlare di planning
intelligenza artificiale
ora pensate che questi grossi argomenti
per cui si occupano ora appunto la
società più grosse del mondo tra cui
quelli che abbiamo visto prima nella
slide dei contributori di linux
lo fanno ma lo fa nota subito in open
source e signori di google dicono usate
il nostro software contribuite prendete
lo mandano in giro delle persone per
spiegare come funziona per attirare la
gente hanno capito che è il modello
vincente e come signori di google ci
sono i signori facebook ci sono anche se
i cinesi di baido è una cosa
interessante perché finora è un
continente rimasto un po fuori da questo
discorso
ma al di là di questo tool facendo un
altro passo indietro mi hanno parlato di
collaborazione abbiamo parlato di
robotica di deep learning tanti paroloni
però pensiamoci un attimo c'è un'idea
sbagliata che quella che l'età
dell'informazione sia nata con il
computer ingegneri informazione data
informazione ita informati e nasce con
questa cosa che ho le mie spalle che
hanno nei primi esempi di scrittura
quindi nasce quando siamo passati dalla
preistoria alla storia che è quello che
convenzionalmente viene indicato come
l'invenzione della scrittura
questo all'adesione informazione
codificabile pensate un'idea
potentissima improvvisamente ha permesso
organizzazioni sociali ha permesso città
lo sviluppo dell'agricoltura del
commercio che prima erano impensabili
tanto da meritare un suo nome ha
iniziato la storia però se ne avanti un
po di anni non signora in germania 1846
dottor macchina da stampa di questa
facciamoci ma sei diventato la viva di
gutenberg
ma questo sembrava solo un cambio di
qualità no a questo l'informazione
replicabile e replicabile su larga scala
questa cosa un altro impatto
potentissimo dopo subito dopo i vari
vesalio copernico i vari newton galileo
hanno potuto scambiare idee con i
colleghi su scala molto più grande ad
attori avevo il seno scientifica e
quindi a quell industria le prime
ragioni noti sono anche altre tappe
all'inizio secolo scorso sforzo bellico
spesso è uno stimolo per industriarsi
siamo arrivati con i vari signori
touring von neumann ad avere
informazioni in forma eseguibile quindi
pensate a ogni tassello che andiamo ad
aggiungere a questa pila di qualità che
stiamo dando un'informazione cosa
facciamo una avanti veloce ai nostri
giorni
qualcuno li conosce questo è il primo
server web installato da tim berners lee
di ginevra 1800 1989 90 e questo
inizialmente sembrava solo un modo un po
più furbo di usare una rete che già
esisteva che era internet o arpanet
realtà questo è stato il quarto salto di
qualità e per questo secondo me si può
parlare di storia 4.0 perché ha riso
un'informazione generabile
collettivamente mettendo a disposizione
gli strumenti per farlo
questo è alla base tutti i vari
strumenti di sviluppo se siete a uno
sviluppatore software conoscete guitar
anche semplicemente il fatto di potersi
scambiare messaggi e mail con
sviluppatori tutto il mondo reso
possibile inox che guarda caso è partito
nel 91
vi faccio anche nota un'altra cosa
questi passaggi sono venuti su una scala
temporale che andata via via
assottigliandosi sono stati da migliaia
di anni a centinaia di anni a decine di
anni forse ci troviamo di nuovo tra
qualche anno e parleremo di un ulteriore
passaggio
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]